CONVENE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY TO
LOSING COMMUNICATIONS TO HEAR
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE
PRESENTATION TODAY -- EVERY BILL
OF IS EITHER GOING TO BE HEARD
IN DIFFERENT TIME OR WAS -- WITH
HELD BY THE AUTHORS -- I DON'T
HAVE THE DETAILS OF THAT YET
HOWEVER.
OF THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
CALENDAR TODAY WE HAVE TWO BILLS
ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER FOUR A.
B. NINE FIVE SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP.
THEN ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHT A
BEEF. ONE FIVE ONE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PANIC PATTERSON
BEFORE WE COMMENCE OF JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
AND WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING --
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TEN SEVENTY
BY NINE BY SOMEONE OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLEASE.
I THINK THIS WE ARE FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT.
ALL THE THE WHAT WE TALKED THE
MANAGERS OF TECHNICAL BY NATURE
AND IT'S VERY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL SIMPLY
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TEST --
THOSE NUMBERS ONE LISTED SO THAT
IF AN EMERGENCY HAPPENS -- WE
KNOW WHETHER THEY WORK OR NOT --
CURRENTLY WE CAN COMMUNICATE
WITH THOSE NUMBERS OTHER
UNDERSTOOD IF THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY -- BUT WE FEEL WE
SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE SOME --
BEFORE THAT HAPPENS.
ALSO THANK YOU VERY MUCH EXPECT
LAST NIGHT OF THANK YOU --
CENTER DOT.
BILL WE HAVE A WE CAN'T MOVE YET
WERE.
IF THIS IS JUST AN OPPORTUNITY
ASK QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE ONEWE NEED ONE MORE
MEMBER BEFORE WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS POINT.
I JUST WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL -- SAYS WE'RE WAITING I
JUST WANTED YOU TOSHARE A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF TIMELINE ONE
OR ARE YOU PLANNING. TO TO DO
THE TESTING JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY WILL JUST ALLOWS LOCAL --
THE LOCALS TO BE ABLE GET WE
DON'T DETERMINE WHEN THE TESTING
HAPPENS -- BUT WHEN THEY DO
TESTING -- THERE'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF NUMBERS OR EXCLUDE
SOME HAVE A TIME LINE IN FRONT
OF ME IT DEPENDS ON WHEN THE
LOCAL -- WHEN THE LOCAL REGION
TO TERMS ARE GOING TO BE TESTING
WE JUST WANT THOSE PARTICULAR
NUMBERS ARE TO BE INCLUDED --
WITHIN THE TESTING.
THANK YOU.
WHEN AN AND JUST BEFORE OF?
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD WOULD WISH TO
COMMENT ON THIS BILL OR PROVIDE
ANY.
A AND IT.
OKAY -- CENTER GOT SO ALREADY ON
ON THE SYSTEM THERE IS A YOU
KNOW SOME NUMBER OF OPT OUTS IS
THAT WOULD.
WITH THIS IS TRYING TO GET AT
WHAT WILL ONLY SAY THIS WAY SO
IF I'M A PERSON WHO CALLS MY MY
PROVIDER AND SAYS.
I WANT TO BE ON THE NEW DOT DO
WE ON THE I DON'T WANT MY NUMBER
PUBLIC I DON'T WANT TO BE
CONTACTED ETCETERA.
I'M OFF THAT LIST.
THEY ARE NOT TESTED THOSE
NUMBERS ARE NOT TESTED ON
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEMS.
HOWEVER WHEN EMERGENCY HAPPENS
IN OUR CONTACTED.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS IS
GET THEM TESTED TO THE MURDER IF
AN EMERGENCY HAPPENS.
WE AT LEAST KNOW WHETHER THEY
WORK OR NOT.
BECAUSE THE CUSTOM MADE NO SENSE.
I TO ALERT -- OKSANEN HAVE A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF TO HAVE A
CERTAIN NUMBERS.
I'D BETTER.
ON CONTACT DOUBLE WE DON'T KNOW
UNTIL THAT EMERGENCY HAPPENS.
SO JUST A SO SO AT THE END OF
THE DAY THIS IS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF TESTING BUT THOSE PEOPLE ARE
IN.
WHEN THERE IS AN EMERGENCY YES
OKAY?
RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible]
PRESIDENT.
HUESO PRESENT MORE LOCK BRADFORD
CHIANG.
CHAIN HERE.
DODD.
DODD HERE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL HERE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT SKINNER
[inaudible]
STERN.
STERN HERE STONE.
DOWN HERE WINNER.
WIENER PRESENT WE HAVE A QUORUM
OFFICIALLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO HAVE A MOTIONS.
THAT ARE DONE MADE A MOTION.
BURKE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN SEVENTEEN NINETY PASSES
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
WESSEL I WAS SO I AM MORE LOCK
BRADFORD CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD DODD AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN ICE DOWN STONE I WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE PREFER ABSENT
MEMBERS -- COULD WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MR WE HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU
SIR ASSEMBLYMEMBER CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AB NINE FIVE SIX IN AB.
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN WESTELL FIVE
WEST SO I AM MORE LOCK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHING CHANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE STONE.
DOWN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN THE ROLE
ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- TO PASS THEM
INTO THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE
[inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HERTZBERG.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER
[inaudible]
TEAMS.
WHETHER OR NOT AS WE'RE GOING TO
REOPEN THE ROLE IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOORLACH MORE LIKE I HERTZBERG
SKINNER [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY -- IN FOR REPAIR.
IF.
YOU'RE NOT [inaudible]
YEAH.
LET ME GET YOU.
AGAIN LEAST FAVORITE.
GLAZER MORE WE'RE GONNA PROS
ROLE